the cast of squid game had to commit 100
to intense requirements including
gaining weight enduring extreme
conditions and total confidentiality
the amount of physical stamina the
actors in squid games show is pretty
incredible and what makes it more
impressive is the fact that it's all
real the actors in the show had to stay
extremely fit so when they weren't
working hard on set they had to be
working out at the gym to make sure
they'd be able to achieve what was
needed everything from being able to
jump far enough during glass stepping
stones pulling during tug of war or
hanging onto the rope as it fell off the
edge battling other players viciously
all of this required a ton of strength
and agility so everyone had to make sure
they were in top form and able to
perform the impressive feats multiple
times on demand
filming for squid game didn't exactly
happen from nine to five every day
depending on the needs of the scene the
actors sometimes had extremely early
morning calls or they began late and
worked all through the night many hours
were spent on set and each one was
precious making these long days very
intense and exhausting for the actors
not to mention the crew who arrived
first and were the last to leave
such crazy hours we would expect plenty
of nice long breaks for the cast when
they were on set to rest and recover
while they did have a netflix budget
time is money and any breaks taken while
filming had to be short to make sure
they didn't fall behind schedule so many
of the scenes required a huge setup and
clean up afterwards so they had to be
very diligent about timing and getting
the takes right efficiently
if any of the actors received an
individual interview request it was a
no-go unless first cleared by the
production team with such a major show
and all the netflix hype the performers
of squid game have rocketed to worldwide
stardom and loads of fans want to hear
more from them the producing team for
the kdrama was on top of everything
though marketing the show taking care of
their artists and making sure everything
went according to plan it might seem
intense but running a show this big
takes a lot of organization and work
it's evident the squid game crew is
pretty incredible at what they do
while everyone in the cast had to work
out and stay in shape in order to
perform each day the actor who played
doksu had to start work earlier since he
also needed to gain nearly 40 pounds as
well it was really important in the show
for his character to have a large
physical build and this was definitely
one rule not broken this intense
physical transformation did come at a
cost though the combination left the
actor exhausted really feeling the
effects on set in his body but he
continued to push his limits every day
his body couldn't quite take it anymore
when filming tug of war
between takes the always tough duck sue
was throwing up from physical exertion
and discomfort even after filming
wrapped the actor continued to
experience negative effects
when these actors were cast contracts
had to be signed and those included
strict confidentiality agreements the
actors had to be tight-lipped and
discreet about the show making sure not
to give away any details even if they
seemed insignificant as we know from
watching squid game pretty well nothing
we see doesn't have some other meaning
while they were working on such an
exciting show and may have wanted to
share stories from the set the only
people the cast could talk about their
work to were other cast members the
secrets of the set even had to be kept
from their closest friends and family
after a long hard day's work plenty of
people want to have a drink and let off
some steam but not everyone is in the
cast of squid game the sabiok actress is
pretty used to the model lifestyle late
nights big parties great drinks
and she loves it
the actress was often eager to go out
after work but her invites to fellow
castmates typically were declined since
the actors had physically mentally and
emotionally intense work to do every day
they couldn't afford to have anything
negatively affect them anupam tripathi
may be a breakout netflix star but he's
also still an acting student the
performer was filming full time for
squid game while also devoting
significant time to his thesis his show
schedule filming was hectic enough
itself so adding all the extra work that
comes with working on a thesis during
supposed down time definitely makes for
a tough experience
i had to finish my thesis also but still
it's going on let's see how it turned
out tripathy had to make sure neither
would conflict with the other so he
could stay focused all the while giving
100 to both he was definitely worn
pretty thin by the end but fortunately
he loves what he does and has a great
attitude about being a student of acting
forever just another reason to be
impressed by this amazing performer cool
is it just us or are the rules of the
actual squid game pretty confusing
whether or not the actors had actually
played or known these games during their
childhoods everyone got pretty familiar
with the activities by the end of
filming these performers couldn't just
act out what they were doing and have
stunt doubles come in and take over when
the time came for the intense games
every actor had to really understand how
to play they weren't messing around even
the dalgon honeycomb candies were real
definitely a tricky one especially for
those unfortunate players in the
umbrella category
there were plenty of scenes when the
actor's real-life fear was perfect for
the cameras
like the overwhelming energy in the tug
of war or the trembling hands during the
honeycomb game however there were
moments that actors had to be up close
and personal with danger whether it was
facing a weapon or trying not to move
while their hearts were racing during
red light green light it was vital for
the actors not to flinch no matter how
exhausted or nervous they may have been
in overwhelming scenes in order to
capture what needed to happen
the vip room holds a lot of strange
vibes from all of its guests being
masked to the real human animal hybrid
living statues these aren't shockingly
realistic props the actors who were cast
as these roles were required to be
covered in full body paint and behave
still as statues their eerie presence is
incredible and they really make an
impact even if they are just in the
background
just tell us about the next game the
sabiok actress isn't from the same
region as her character is in the show
so she had to make sure to hide her own
accent as it's different from how she
needed to sound before she started
filming the actress had to work
diligently with an accent coach to help
her sound authentic and throughout
filming it was something she always had
to keep an ear out for since the wrong
accent would be noticeable to anyone who
knew the region and it would have broken
the illusion of realism we get
throughout the show
there's no question the entire team
behind squid games total commitment was
key in making the show the success it's
become actors like the one who played
doksu were also working through muscle
loss and joint pain while filming this
production was nothing but impressive
and intense